hey there DC collectible fans 2016 marks
Wonder Woman's 75th anniversary and DC
collectibles is celebrating big day
viewing a special Wonder Woman art of
war statue featuring an all-star
all-female creative team this incredible
statue is based on the amazing artwork
of Amanda Connor sculpted by Karen
palenko painted by Kim dullahan and art
directed by Janice Walker from DC
creative services DC collectibles
launched the Wonder Woman art of war
statue line in 2013 as a way of bringing
the interpretations of some of the
greatest Wonder Woman artist in history
to three-dimensional life Janice's keen
eye for detail and design paved the way
for Amanda Connor to create a few
gorgeous and dynamic sketches of Wonder
Woman the warrior equipped with armor
headdress shield and spear once landing
on the final concept amanda moved on to
type pencil turnarounds showing detailed
front side and back views karen
polenta's years of sculpting experience
made her an obvious choice for capturing
Amanda's vision she was tasked with
interpreting Amanda's 2d art style into
3d form and ensuring the Statue met
appropriate height requirements that
accessories used correct materials and
that construction of the materials would
break down into functional tool parts
for manufacturing the finished sculpture
along with color guides were given to
painter Kim della Han to bring the
statue to life with color an earlier
statue from The Art of War Wonder Woman
line was also used to ensure that the
color palette remained consistent using
her variety of brushes like precision
power tools
Kim steady hand applied paint along
Wonder Woman's form honing in on even
finer details with clean lines the
finished product poses a striking
reminder that this Wonder Woman Art of
War statue is a tour de force
masterfully created constructed and a
perfect tribute to the Amazon princess
pick up yours today online or at your
nearest comic shop
happy Anniversary Wonder Woman
you